There's nothing that brings me more joy than cookie dough ice cream,
and this joyforia fragrance by Charlotte Tilbury
reminded me of just that. Smells warm and radiant with hints of vanilla,
cash Niroly, and Jasmine.
Brings me so much happiness.
So obviously I associate that one of my favorite ice cream flavors,
which is cookie dough ice cream.
Warm up my milk, vanilla,
and sugar on the top and then temper my eggs
before pouring the mixture back into my pot and letting it thicken.
Once it was thick enough to coat the back of my spoon,
I strained it and combined it with some heavy cream
before letting it chill in the fridge.
In the meantime, I got started on making my cookie dough
and combined some butter and sugar.
Once that was all combined,
I added all of my dry ingredients,
which were some flour, baking soda,
baking powder, and some chopped up chocolate.
Once that was all combined,
I rolled my cookie dough into little balls
and put them on a baking sheet,
which I then put in the freezer until all my balls were frozen.
In the meantime, I started churning my ice cream.
Once it hit the consistency I wanted,
I added my frozen cookie dough
and let that churn for a couple minutes longer.
That looked ready to me. I transferred it over to my storage container,
topped it with some more of the cookie dough
and some leftover chocolate.
I popped this In the freezer for another four hours.
The taste of this ice cream brought me so much joy.